the film franchise that title has caused
more parents to raise their eyebrows at
their children than Vin Diesel's xxx
franchise has a sequel the most
requested sequel of all time the nutjob
too nutty by Nature and I went and saw
it today because I can do anything i sat
through the emoji movie I have
superpowers I can do anything that I
want nothing fazes me I can sit through
Dragon Ball it no I can't do that I
guess I still have a kryptonite I hadn't
seen the first one so since I actually
wanted to attempt to review this movie I
watched it last night on Amazon Prime
it's a bland but colorful kids movie not
offensive but it's there
what a horrible title oh my god so I
went to the theater today and I
approached the box office and I said to
the nice lovely cashier one for the
worst titled movie in existence please
and she went the nutjob too and I went
yes and she went here you go I like that
cashier she was spunky the first one was
about the squirrels needing food their
food supply was dwindling and they found
a nut store where they could have a
bunch of exotic nuts whenever they
wanted this one is also about them
finding food for a while at first until
their shop blows up and oh what are
they gonna do in fact I have a feeling
that filmmakers we're also thinking oh
what are we going to do we're
making another nutjob movie why are we
doing that I guess because the first one
was modestly successful and kids want
more so what the hell are we going to do
I know get an evil politician to develop
land on their Park a pudgy politician
with orange hair who wants to destroy
everything in his path I see what they
did there we have here yet another
animated film about a money-grubbing
maniac who wants to destroy animals I
was old when norm of the North did it
norm of
Norris did it why would you do that
again and even though they do actually
put forth effort into some of their
jokes the film just isn't that clever
even if the marketing campaign paid
homage to Monty Python and the Holy
Grail but honestly it is very easy to
hate on this movie it's a sequel no one
asked for it's strictly for kids and
it's admittedly not very good but unlike
the recent animated version of cancer on
film this movie at least doesn't pander
to children
it doesn't bombard them with endless
product placements it doesn't tell them
that the rest of their lives should be
filled with nothing but downloading apps
and sending texts to people and it
certainly doesn't make kids feel like
idiots it has some good messages
involved in it as well and the messages
aren't hidden under a pile of corporate
garbage pretty much any animated movie
is going to look amazing when compared
to that thing but all that being said it
was refreshing to see a film that was
made for kids for kids to enjoy this
movie isn't going to win any awards it's
going to be made fun of a lot for its
title but kids are going to have fun
watching it and it is very least that's
something I can say that's praiseworthy
about what is mostly a very bland dull
unfunny movie I'm going to give the nut
job to nutty by nature of see it be easy
to sit here and really hate this movie
and just talk about how horrible it is
but there's really nothing in it to get
mad about it's just a bland unwanted
sequel guys thank you very much as
always for watching look forward to more
Stephen King reviews this weekend and if
you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
[Music]